こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんが意地の1反射したい人いますか
2してはいけませんけ頃の感謝の伝え方まあいろいろ物をあげたりとかプレゼントをし
たりとかあってお祝いしたいとかいろいろあると思うんですけども直接言うか
恥ずかしかったり
まあ今ちょっと沿いは何かあったりするの良くないみたいです v 字形だねぇ遊ぼう
のプレゼントを買ったりするとそ選ぶのをちょっと難しいねってとかあると思うんです
よね
普通壁今回僕がつかんだもう
みんなが入ってるラインでですね line ゲストというものが送れるんですよ今日
はそれを僕の愛して愛してやまない姫一目指したら子女
ヒカキン親分に何かお正月とかも最近なんかそういう感謝の気持ちを込めて旧がい
なかったのでライン月だったら直接会わなくてもいわゆるんでちょっとおやぶのないん
ですね
白旗山ギフトを送りつけてみようかと思います
4日
愛を伝えるハイテクで早速ヒカキンさんとのトーク line ですよいいですよ
菊花姫札ライン撮ってるんだよ僕そもそも line ギフトとは何かと言いますと
今 line も line が守っていれば凄くいます line で友達にギフト
とが多く良い奴なんですね
くらいでできましたラインギフトですめっちゃランドヴァルザーもうライン際入れてれ
ば誰でも送れます
今みたいにパワーそしてポッチってライフとてもこれでねぇなんでもあげるんですよ僕
のヒカキンさんの愛は無限大びっくりするぐらい僕の愛を1月に伝えたいと思います木
さんはよく見ずにお仕事するんですよねポスター
もう
持っています
グルーほんの気持ちですできました覚えじゃあ
はいども火加減さから書きましたおはようムーこれもらっていいの小籔が悪いがて
ありがとうてって帰ってきました
こんなんでどうあればいいはどんどん遅れつけましょう親船この高級チョコレートに
よってゴディバ入っちゃいましょう
ソフトフィール食べて割れそういう部分にどんどんいきますよ早めにもう一個
モンスター買ってあげました
なにこれおいしぞ4,000円しますからねこれチョンドいけますよ
モスバーガーを来た
県はねつぶ野菜もと当選で毛布野菜バーガーのソイパリ編効果を送りましょう僕の木も
ちゃん止まりませ
たくさんあげましょうもうこれも
あっ払ってるううううう親分が笑ってますん
24だけどチーズケーキこれを買っていきましょう飛ばすちょうっ
どんどんここからね度上げていきますよ何か物とか持ってるんだねすごい男性への
誕生日いいですね
おお凄い凄い数がめっちゃめっちゃある価格を選べるんだ親分
一番いいぞキャプションまっハッチばオーダーだ
ああああああ
だから部分でこのさなる家城ビルのフィギュア
はっはっはっ
これ笑って嬉しいのかでほんと何年も浮かれすぎてやばいんだけど
日本グランド牛6000ミニステーチケットをかけました
ムラっけさんだらすごい光栄で高いはのばっかりじゃなくて32円のやつとかも送れる
んですね
もう初めからのシーンだけですねスプーンワッってしないですね合わせてくださいって
言っておりますね
それでは契約成立ということで今後よろしくお願いしますお化けははこれ傾げを充電式
ヘッド種スパートやばいなこれ本当に中本実用的なものも買ってあげたいな
蟹づくしのたそうすっとちょっと食べ物上げすぎたらこのマグと及ぶ太っ積んで
かにバスが大好きかわいい
web 台車を防ぐ台車ユーチューバーものを運ぶことが多いと思いで台車るテープ
いろいろ本で強そうな気がするんですね台車を切りました
はっはってるうううううっ
伺い台車をよくいらんかなあっていうのもの波止1部第じゃいらないんだ
じゃあこれまぞこれは喜んでくれず早速に待ってえぐいでよかった削ってるなぁ
いやーこんなにギフトの種類あるってやばいなをこのこのちゃんが好きでで巻いて食べ
てマジで
ぽ県と15980の声とありますね
どんな憑依し5月に食べさせてあげたいこれ見嬉しいですね
あっはぁもうグーッと上げてきちゃったーーーー
高級
もうさすがに大丈夫よありがとうございます
破産すぐに戻っ
[音楽]
五條市あっ惜しくを作る様ねえ
おはようおはようございます
なんでこんなにくれるんですか水はで最近親分に開いてなくて感謝を伝えようと思って
line ギフトでたくさん送らせていただきました
ん
えんだろ俺らがもういいよテーマで送り続ければなんかやってんな
[音楽]
ブーバーレッサーっ人とか
ん
持っていってくださいとか
なんか結構良い奴のや衣裳着言っを入れてくださいさあ
言えようと知らないですかまぁハズレかちょっとほんとぜひ受け取ってくるんであれば
いいや網膜から小矢部の愛でございますもう感謝の
重さ
主入ってる数字ではいけませんすー
ああっ絶対まあ数値動くってやってようですお詫びこう言うね何か申し訳ないことし
たら
ob 1分けでいうはいこれで広
ごめんなさいとパティも伝えてこれが line ですとでございますこんな簡単に
気持ちを伝えられるそれもみんな
使っている line を使って line ギフトマジで優れてますなぁこういう
時期なんでなかなか会えないと思うんですけども
それでも僕たちは line でつながっています line ギフトぜひ今会えない
人とかに贈り物を上げてみてください本当色んな所に行ってるびっくりして俺はパス
なんとこの動画概要欄であるリンクからですね
20%オフのクーポンがもらえますのでそちらぜひ使ってみてくださいって拡大
でもう行くぐらいならを来た毛をボディミルクのジャスミンに贈ったゲオで着くれまし
た
ボディ魅力を送ってあげました
ヒュー do